Speaker 1: Later in the show, I'm going to
have clips for you, a Fox News propagandist,
Tucker Carlson, who almost certainly has been
vaccinated for a really long time, spreading
the debunked, unsubstantiated claim that vaccines
might be killing thousands of people.
Now, I've been getting calls from people for
a year at this point or not.
No, not quite.
That's an exact eight months or so saying,
David, the covid vaccine is killing people.
This has been floating around for a while,
but it's really growing now just as one.
But it's mostly happening on Facebook.
But just as a reminder, here is video we looked
at last week.
This was the Gavin Newsom Joe Biden rally
the day before the California recall.
This is the California recall last Tuesday,
which went horribly wrong for Republicans.
And you've got to listen closely.
But one of the arguments happening outside
was with a woman claiming that more people
died from the covid vaccine than from the
flu.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: We've been in public health until
you return.
I know it's going to go on.
I don't think
Speaker 1: so.
Just give it time.
Remember, the woman on the right is the woman
arguing about the economy.
Air Force mom in the blue shirt is the one
spreading the vaccine death conspiracies.
It's going to focus in on her in a moment.
No, you
Speaker 2: don't wait a day.
I don't even know.
I know.
I want to have hundreds of.
Speaker 1: And these audio problems are in
the clip, I apologize, in less
Speaker 2: than one year, in less than one
year.
Sweetheart, I have no idea how many people
died from the lack.
Tired from the action and one, why do you
want it?
Speaker 1: OK, so this is getting a lot of
attention and it's important to remind you
that there is no evidence that people are
dying from the vaccine.
So PolitiFact flags this as having sort of
started with Facebook posts on August 24th.
It's older than that.
But OK, for the purposes of today, the claim
was hundreds of thousands died after taking
the advice of these celebrities who are aiding
and abetting mass murder by advocating vaccination.
Now, the if your time is short summary from
PolitiFact is there is no evidence of covid
vaccines causing deaths.
According to the CDC, there is no evidence
that covid-19 vaccines have caused any deaths
in the United States.
This was then updated.
There is a twenty four minute video slamming
celebrities for recommending the vaccines,
says the vaccines have killed hundreds of
thousands of people.
The text at the start of the video says, quote,
You may never trust another celebrity.
After watching this video.
Hundreds of thousands died after taking the
advice of these celebrities.
Should they be tried for murder, aiding and
abetting mass murder through vaccination,
all for population control.
Facebook did ultimately take that down.
And as the article points out, covid has killed
nearly six hundred seventy five thousand in
the US and more than four and a half million
worldwide.
The vaccines authorized in the U.S. have been
shown to significantly reduce the likelihood
of severe illness, hospitalization and death.
And no evidence has established that a covid-19
vaccine authorized in the U.S. has caused
any deaths, let alone hundreds of thousands.
I think it's important to be precise there.
We really don't know what's going on with
some of these other vaccines in other countries.
They haven't been evaluated by the American
FDA and the reporting around their side effects
is, you know, incomplete at best.
So we're not saying anything one way or the
other.
I have no reason to think the Russian vaccine
or the Chinese vaccine are killing people.
I have family in Argentina that have gotten
those vaccines.
The article, though, is being specific and
precise, saying the vaccines authorized in
the United States, we have no evidence to
suggest that those are killing people.
So, unfortunately, you know, when the situation
escalates, the conspiracy theories seem to
escalate as well.
And now they're just straight up saying hundreds
of thousands dead from the vaccines without
any evidence whatsoever.
Later in the show, we are going to talk about
Tucker Carlson signal boosting this false
claim.
And we're going to talk about how easy it
is.
I didn't do it, but I went through and started
going through the process to see how easy
it is.
It is so easy to submit a false vaccine side
claim up to and including death in what's
called the Veirs system Vassar's that you
may well have reports of deaths that are unsubstantiated
as well.
So we're going to get to that a little bit
later.
If you know people in your personal life who
are who are repeating this one, thousands
dead, hundreds of thousands dead from the
vaccines, I want to hear from you.
OK, find me on Twitter at David Pakman or
shoot us an email info at David Pakman dot
com.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is made
possible by viewers and listeners who sign
up on our website and get a membership, we
do a commercial free audio and video version
of the show for our members.
We also do an extra show every day called
The Bonus Show Only for you.
You can get instant access by signing up at
join Pakman Dotcom